[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france24
soy marina colorado la script o monedas
aunque aún no son de uso generalizado
entre la ciudadanía han llegado para
quedarse y con ellas su consumo de
energía que se traduce en emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero a la
atmósfera en este programa intentaremos
explicarles por qué consumen tanta
electricidad y por qué no todas las que
toman edas son comparables en cuanto a
su impacto ambiental para entender el
consumo de estas primero hay que
explicar su funcionamiento la mayoría de
la escrito moneda se basa en la
tecnología de block change o cadena de
bloques un modelo para realizar
transacciones sin necesidad de
intermediarios cada bloque o transacción
tiene cierta información que ha de ser
verificada por los demás usuarios antes
de poder llevarse a cabo una vez
validado el bloque éste queda registrado
de manera codificada y descentralizada
en una cadena que hace las veces del
libro contable o de base de datos con
todas las transacciones realizadas en el
mundo esto significa que el intercambio
de dinero o servicios que usen esta
tecnología sea mucho más transparente y
difícil de falsificar
embargo no todas las criptas están
diseñadas de la misma manera y ahí es
donde la huella ambiental de cada una
difiere nos lo explica mauro a curso de
southall empresa que desarrolla e
implementa proyectos y estrategias de
reducción y compensación de emisiones
para compañías gobiernos y
organizaciones
bueno para empezar es importante que las
cripto monedas
justamente piensen en el tema ambiental
desde el diseño no desde el inicio
porque hay distintas formas de cripto
maneras las más tradicionales
funcionan con el eliminado como bitcoin
y eso se llama proof of work en la
industria o prueba de trabajo significa
que hay computadoras detrás gastando
mucha energía para resolver acertijos
matemáticos y eso básicamente consume
energía lo cual consume combustibles
fósiles no sobre todo hoy es el carbón
en china que es donde mucho se hizo del
vino decreto monedas aunque ahora se
está cambiando entonces el diseño ya es
cripto monedas
que funcionan de otra forma de lo que se
llama proof of state o prueba de
participación que básicamente reduce
casi el 100% ese consumo de energía
porque no se tiene que hacer eliminado
entonces eso es fundamental entender el
impacto ambiental desde el diseño mismo
de la cripto moneda desde sus mecanismos
de funcionamiento
pero una vez que se entiende eso digamos
seguir también está la posibilidad de
que las cripto monedas y que ese consumo
energético funcione con renovables
hoy en día se calcula que más o menos el
40 por ciento de virtual podría estar
funcionando con renovables pero no hay
mucha información porque justamente al
ser descentralizada en la red no se sabe
exactamente todos los detalles lo que sí
se sabe es que la minería de bitcoin
consume más energía que naciones como
argentina o países bajos pero como
decíamos no toda la escritura monedas
son iguales y hay varias que no entran
en la lista negra ambiental por así
decirlo entre ellas están solar coin big
green o hada cardano decidión la segunda
más relevante después de bitcoin pasará
en los próximos meses existe de prueba
de participación lo que hará que su
consumo energético baje en más de un 99
9% además existe una iniciativa
impulsada por el sector privado e
inspirada en el acuerdo de parís que
pretende acelerar el desarrollo de
soluciones verdes para este tipo de
monedas en concreto y para la tecnología
de cadena de bloques en general si es el
quinto que el meta core es un acuerdo
voluntario de la industria de script o
monedas que como comentaba el objetivo
principal lo envía llegar al 100% de
energías renovables para 2025 y después
ir ampliando ese objetivo no para ir al
lo que se llama ser emisiones netas que
es el objetivo a nivel global para 2050
y entre otras iniciativas está por
ejemplo hacer un software código abierto
que permite a las empresas
contabilizar sus emisiones para saber
exactamente cuánta energía consume ni
cuántas emisiones de co2 equivalente
están emitiendo y el último aspecto que
por ahora
acordados es poder digamos eventualmente
compensar con créditos de carbono las
emisiones históricas no mirar para atrás
hacer el cálculo de cuánto se emitió a
la atmósfera disfrutar de compensarlo
con con proyectos que remuevan co2 de la
atmósfera
con este acuerdo si todas las que toman
eras deciden basarse en energías
renovables la discusión sobre su impacto
ambiental podría dejarse de lado y si
bitcoin que usa el método más
contaminante de minería llamado prueba
de trabajo usará electricidad limpia y
demandará este tipo de energía podría
impulsar una aceleración en el ritmo de
desarrollo de las renovables en el mundo
pero más allá de su uso en cripto
monedas la tecnología block change es
una gran aliada en la protección del
medio ambiente puede prevenir la pérdida
de información aumentar la transparencia
de las cuentas del sector público o
reforzar la implementación de acuerdos
multilaterales también ayuda en la
trazabilidad de servicios o del origen
de productos como la madera o la pesca
para saber por ejemplo si provienen de
la industria ilegal las posibilidades
son muchas aunque los retos no se quedan
atrás así llegamos al final de este
programa pero antes un mensaje 24 años
de traerles cada semana la información
medioambiental a través de la pantalla
de france 24 me despido de este espacio
un espacio que considero esencial en los
medios de comunicación sobre todo en
españa' pero aunque yo les digo adiós el
compromiso de france 24 con la
información ambiental continuará
semanalmente de la mano de nuestra
compañera maría clara calle ha sido un
honor y un placer hasta siempre
[Música]